foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone how's it going
welcome to the second day of next and to
our encryption breakout session keys to
the kingdom thank you so much for coming
my name is Marcus Hartwig I'm a product
marketer here at Google Cloud security
and
it's Now official data is the most
valued resource in the world it's
actually a head of oil according to the
economist but I think that mostly people
here in the room will agree with me when
I say that not only is data just a
valued resource it is in fact something
that is quite critical for most
businesses
and that's why I compose such a huge
risk if it were to be processed or
handled or
operated Pawn in a way that goes against
compliance and regulation or if it was
even misplaced or leaked summer
now here at Google Cloud we've designed
and built our cloud from the ground up
with security and privacy in mind
we have a wide variety of features and
controls to help you keep your data
secure in Google cloud and we truly
believe that the best place and the most
cost effective way to secure that data
is to have it in our cloud
now one of the most powerful controls
that you can have when it comes to data
security is of course data encryption we
offer data encryption for data in
transit
data at rest and data in use
now data encryption of data in transit
is really valuable if you want to
protect that data as it moves from your
devices to Google Cloud
an encryption of data at rest is really
important when you want to protect the
data that is being stored in Google
Cloud
but equally important is protection of
data in use
with protection on an encryption of data
in use you can protect your data as it
is being used by Google cloud services
and that's really important because you
want to be able to use your data as it
stays secured for things like indexing
or training or inference of AI and ml
models
so data encryption in a nutshell is
essential for protecting your data from
unauthorized access but it's really only
as good as if you have control over the
encryption keys that sort of lock in
that encryption of data now we offer a
wide variety of of features and and
controls for Key Management Solutions so
that you can select the one that best
fits your organization and your own
needs
but not only that we also want to make
it easy and intuitive to use so that
anyone can take advantage of these
offerings and security controls even
those who are not cryptographers at
heart so developers or regularly just
Cloud users for us
we've made a large amount of very very
good
increments and product improvements to
our KMS portfolio over the year and
we're incredibly excited to tell you
about them so I'd like to invite Nelly
Porter on stage and she can tell you
what we have going on welcome Nelly
thank you so much Marcus
at least we clap done hello thank you so
much can you hear me first of all talk
about it okay
thank you so much for coming I'm Nelly
Porter I own encryption end-to-end and
gcp in Google
and today I am going to tell you a lot
of interesting stories so Story number
one
my customers coming to us and saying
Okay Google
they need to not only protect our data
with your very important encryption keys
but we also need to make sure that we
can perform the basic data life cycle
operation like delete my data
or do data retention policy or wipe out
my data and again for all of you that
brave enough to attend our session
understand that encryption is probably
the best tool to accomplish that because
instead of hunting for every single file
a single object or every single table in
data sets you can simply delete the keys
and get this data deleted but then
you need to own those keys
and it's exactly what we want to offer
you without cloud Key Management
solution
so as you would expect from cloud KMS no
surprise
we really solid cloud and mature native
service
we have ability to be Global whenever
you want us
we actually have not only Global
deployment but reliability scalability
availability is of all things that you
need
very recently we are announcing new
services in area of transparency and
it's called key tracking and it's
absolutely trivial
all of you told us okay we need to
ensure that those keys is actually
associated with those objects how do I
know that those objects is actually
protected by those keys and some of you
not you in the audience decided to go
and delete some keys without very clear
validation that then you actually
distract your data and destruct your
data such ways that it's not recoverable
so being able to see being able to track
the keys and resources and those keys
protecting is critical and we have this
capability for you but as usual we don't
stop there
and again what we were thinking about
and it's one additional customer Told Me
Nelly it took me actually two months in
two seconds to put two objects under the
cloud bucket
and I was like it's impossible two
months and two seconds and they said yes
here's the story to create the key
you need to have the biggest admin in
the world key admin creating those keys
and it happened in Europe again some of
you from Europe the patience is really
really low
so when my developer came and trying to
put these two objects onto the bucket
the key was not ready for them because
to create key you need to have this very
powerful
he had been creating this key for this
developer so it took us two months and
two seconds to create this key and
unblock this developer
and we're like okay our current
experience is exactly as you see on the
screen select the key because this key
have to be created but this key admin
but what we're thinking about the
creation of the keys is something that
everybody in your organization can do
but you need to define the policy and
what type of key what type of
cryptography you need to go is it what
type of in rotation policy everything so
it is why
today we're introducing Key Management
autopilot and it's exactly what you
expect Key Management auto pilot is
actually learned from all of you what
keys you creating day and night we
understand this confidence of
99.99999 99 that it's exactly the key
that you need
and we will create those key for you on
behalf with you fully controlling what
keys and how to manage those keys we
also will support and continue
supporting he managed encryption keys or
CMAC as we call when you control every
single step on the way but we add in
those autopilot keys for you so your
developer would not wait two months and
two seconds to put those objects under
the bucket and would be able to continue
what they need in line with the resource
creation
and let me show you is the experience
that you will have and let me see that
it's playing so instead of selecting the
key
evil Health ability to surprise create
the key and we will create this key and
we will create this key the best that we
have in our possession and it will be
Hardware based HSM based keys and you
would be able to update it change it to
do what you need you would have all of
this power in your hands and you will
not spend significant amount of time of
creating those keys and also after
those keys will be created sorry it's a
video is like out of sync you would be
able to see it in our key tracking
dashboards see those keys are created
so welcome to Key Management autopilot
we absolutely looking forward for your
feedback and it's the service that we
will offer in preview and we will bring
it to General availability very soon
so it's actually something that customer
told us Nally it's taken us
quite a bit of time to create all of
those thousands keys and we're spending
years
so we actually a lot lots experiment and
Villa love a lot of data
so we send our developers to figure out
how long it will create one key how long
it will take them even people that know
this stuff
to create this key
approximately 10 12 minutes
so Marcus do you know how many keys we
are actually creating per year
so actually
tens of millions of keys
so take your 12 minutes
multiply by again let's take 25 mL of
keys we're coming to
586 years
we spend it over six centuries on key
creation operation we next year going to
give all of this time back to you so
those key advancements finally would be
able to take vacation and don't worry
that the organization will stop
completely stop of doing what they need
or Story number two
he's a fantastic but we need really
really strong protection of those kids
we have software protection and we have
Hardware protection
and this is recommending that Hardware
keys are becoming more of default or
preferred option for our customers so
what we will do
we actually have
a service for all of you
called Cloud HSM and Cloud HSM
let me bring it to the screen
is actually exactly what it said
It's ability for us to generate and
perform our operation in boundaries of
cloud data terms and usually when you
hear about Cloud digitam those numbers
is thrown at you
fips140-2-3 L2 L3 and it's like bunch of
numbers
for some of you they're joining this
session probably you have very clear
understanding what is the differences
but I want to make very clear Point here
the difference between L2
and L3
temper evidence and temper resistance
and temper evidence in normal human
language sorry we're trying to translate
it a little bit
means that when things happened
and somebody modify or get again
malicious access to those devices after
the fact the devices will report to you
and saying congratulation this happened
temporary system means that those
devices are built such way that they
will resist those changes and it's huge
difference it's why V in Google believe
that when we're talking about Hardware
we're really talking about those very
strong HSM capabilities
next
next story customer saying fantastic so
we have Hardware protection we have
software protection we have sex
autopilot keys
but now sometimes we need to hold our
own Keys close to us we need to have
ability to keep and generate those keys
and perform the operation on those keys
outside of Google cloud and we hear and
we delivered we have what we call Cloud
external key manager so story and it
means you would be able to do it outside
of cloud perform your cryptographic
operation and keep your keys for
yourself managing by yourself
there's the same experiences that we
have today with customer managed
encryption key autopilot keys will not
be supported for eqm
so and then
cloudy Kim is also adding very important
capability
we called it key approval justification
when you have ability to tell
if you accept the access to those keys
or not
so you're putting this the whole entire
policy layer here to make decision if
you allow us to perform this operation
based on our justifications that we
provide or you actually deny access to
the keys so you're not only holding
those keys In This Cloud ekm capability
but you also have the entire policy
level and controls to save photo access
and what are not
great
so then my customer said fantastic
we have ability to protect our data at
rest
but cloud and Google is not the
graveyard
we need this data to be processed we
need this data to be used for our gen AI
models we need this data to be used for
our training our serving it's all what
we need so how we will ensure that the
encryption capabilities that we have
addressed will continue to be preserved
when we trying to process this data and
then Google in 2020
introduce the first product in
confidential Computing space
and confidential Computing space allow
us to provide very strong isolation
capability
so when you bring in your workloads to
us you have this virtualization
isolation capability that provided by
our hypervisor with confidential
Computing using extensions of CPU of
those vendors we started with AMD and by
the way Intel is coming as well be able
to create cryptographic isolation
between different tenants and between
you and us Google to ensure that our
zero days will not be able to interrupt
or influence what is happening in your
workloads and it is done because of keys
but those keys is the best keys that you
want to dream about because it's created
by the Asic this again silicon device
that we have on our motherboard by AMD
or again other vendors and those keys
are staffed into memory controllers so
we were able incredibly fast to encrypt
decrypt our memory when application
trying to access it
and after the data is decrypted it's put
all the
bus lines for CPU to perform operations
and after that it's encrypted back so
it's always encrypted
and the beauty of this system is that
your application doesn't need to change
as soon as it's running in those
boundaries in This Confidential
Computing environments and those tees
it's completely can access everything
that it needs to access but as soon as
you're trying to do exactly the same
operation outside of boundary of your
confidential environment you will see
cyber text
but the keys as I said is a Paramount
it's ephemeral
it's never stored it's Unique for your
confidential environment and it's also
the most important fact not exportable
and it means not us Google not you our
dear customers would be able to get
access to this Keys it's the best keys
to have my opinion
so we introduced confidential VMS
and after that we bring to you
confidential gke our kubernetes managed
Services Google kubernetes engine to
ensure that you would be able to create
the whole entire cluster of those
confidential environments of
confidential nodes or node pools
associated with this cluster
and after that customers said okay
fantastic but what about Hadoop what
about spark what about beam what about
all of this data analytics Services we
also process so much sensitive data
there when we need to do what we need to
do where the confidentiality in that and
it's why we also brought to General
availability confidential data proc
think about spark Hadoop map reduce and
exactly what you ask confidential data
flow our beam ability to for you to
prepare your data before you will be
doing inference training or anything
else with that so Mr sings God we have
all of that but they didn't stop right
there
Story number five customer said Nelly
fantastic thank you so much for
isolating us so well we not only
isolated through virtualization layers
but also through cryptography
cryptographic layers but we need to
collaborate
we need to calibrate among multiple
companies and sometimes those companies
is actually competitors so we can't join
the data we can't do confidential match
what do we do and it's exactly what
we've done by introducing confidential
space
confidential space is the capability
that built specifically for those
customers that need to join sensitive
data that they couldn't do before
we have very interesting customers and
doing money laundering validation
because you can't figure out money
laundering or double spend if you're
only processing your own data you need
to combine the data from multiple
Financial companies financial
institutions to be able to do that but
how you will do it because all of them
compete with each other none of them
trust each other so confidential space
is a solution for this problem because
confidentials face in addition to
interpreting confidentiality
it's offering protection against
workload owner it means irrespectively
if you're running this workload you
would not be able to modify it you only
would be able to start it and kill it
nothing else and it's how you would be
able to guarantee that all of you would
be able to communicate and collaborate
securely
so fantastic one more thing I forgot to
mention one more announcement that we
want to make
more than two years we work in these
fintech companies they're trying to
bring to the clouds of payment
applications and it's everything we ask
our customers to do when they modernism
they're changing the environments we
asking them to lift and shift to their
application and bring it to the cloud
if he also asking them to lift and shift
the data to bring it to the cloud the
question is what to do with those HSM
devices that you need to perform your
payment operation because those payment
HSM is very special devices please don't
leave them behind
we're offering a new service in gcp
called bare metal HSM for payments and
the idea of this service is exactly what
you will ask we will take those hsms
from your hands
PCI certification is actually changed
recently allow you to remote administers
those boxes and it means you can
pick them up if they support remote
Administration and bring it to us
and we will do what we need to do with
those wonderful devices
and it will be fully certified facility
with all of our expertise to help and
take care of those devices you also can
go and buy those HSM from your vendors
because we strongly believe you have
strong relationship with those
HSN payment companies
so what we will do because we will bring
it in our Google extensions and we can
guarantee that the latency of those
operations will say well exactly what
you expect and it's the most important
thing and it's yeah it's physics it's
speed of light you need to bring the
boxes closer to your workloads to ensure
that it has not more than five eight
milliseconds latency we want to ensure
that we will be scalable reliable and
helping you to bring your payments
applications and your payment HSM
together
we also will be able to work with you if
you have to bring General crypto hsms as
well so we are not only talking about
payment hsms but it's probably the most
critical ask that we hear from all of
you today
and I'm done back to you mark thank you
so much Nelly
now
because I'm staying
[Laughter]
none of these hardware-based solutions
would have been possible whatsoever
without our technology partners and we
are lucky to have two of them here today
so I'd like to invite Todd Moore and
Adam Cason on stage from Tallis and from
future X
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
good morning
where do we stand
it's changed I gotta stand under your
picture yeah there you go
so Todd would you mind just taking a
minute and tell us a little bit about
Thomas for those who are not familiar I
know we go way back between Google cloud
and sure so good morning everyone
um from Talus for those of you don't
know who Talus is we're a large global
company based in Paris France we do a
lot of different things we build
satellites we were part of the Mars
rover project we build airplanes and
submarines and things like that we also
have a very large digital security
business where we do a bunch of banking
cards credit cards as well as cyber
security and that's where I'm from and
uh we've been working with Google for a
very long period of time really
appreciate the partnership uh we're a
Google customer Google Cloud customer
and I think what we found working with
Google is we had a lot of expertise and
a lot of things that Nelly talked about
in terms of external key management and
hsms we're really focused on digital
sovereignty being a paris-based company
a European based company we get asked
how do you meet digital sovereignty
requirements around the world so
leveraging some of the constructs that
Google has we've been working together
for a long time we kind of I think of as
a yin yang Google's really good at what
you do from the infrastructure
perspective and we try to bring what we
do from an encryption and Key Management
perspective an external Key Management
perspective so thank you guys for having
us here yeah thanks for coming Adam a
few tricks one of our our newer Partners
in the portfolio I would say I've heard
absolutely well thank you Marcus thank
you Nelly it's been a pleasure being
here so my name is Adam Cason I handle
Partnerships and alliances at futurex
and what we do is focus primarily around
Enterprise Key Management data
protection Hardware security modules for
both payment and general purpose but as
far as the Google relationship here and
our Focus there we've centered that
around a few different use cases Cloud
ekm that we've talked about here today
Google workspace client-side encryption
as well and also the bare metal HSM for
payments that we've discussed today so
you know we're looking forward really to
discussing those and how all of those
interplay with one another and form
really over ecosystem here
thank you so much for coming as well so
we've talked a lot about payment
customers and what makes their needs so
special when it comes to to Hardware
security modules as opposed to any other
customer and I like to read that one too
sure so um
uh from a from a payment HSN perspective
and this is an exciting time with Google
is there's really three you know it
payment HSN is a specialized HSM and it
really I guess three characteristics and
Adam love to hear your opinion as well
too but it really is around payments and
compliance uh you hear about PCI
um you know the payment industry is
always updating the regulation and
compliance you got to make sure that
your HSM is a part of that compliance
chain is certified to the latest
standards so compliance is a very big
important part when it comes to payments
the second element and Nelly touched on
this is speed it's latency so a lot of
folks all of us when we go buy something
with our credit card or our phone we
expected that payment transaction is
going to happen relatively quickly and
it's just one use case but you want the
latency and the time for that to be
relatively quick so there is a latency
component and I guess the third aspect
when it comes to payment functions and
they are very unique is you want your
applications not to change I mean there
are payment applications out there that
have been around for a long time as you
write new applications you want a very
robust API application programming
interface so that your legacy
applications as well as your new
applications can interact with those new
payment functions so payment HSM is a
unique a unique Beast I guess I would
say and as Nelly had said earlier
customers have asked us how can we
leverage our Legacy payment applications
get performance and latency and be able
to get the compliance in a cloud
environment and with bare metal I think
we're being able to do that with Nelly
so but Adam I I might go ahead I didn't
do anything or no that's that's honestly
it's spot on I think you look at the
compliance you look at the speed those
are two big areas of very very important
Focus
payments and the use of Hardware
security modules in payments is one of
if not the oldest use case for them and
so there's a lot of Legacy history
behind all that a lot of reasons why
things are done certain ways from Key
Management from processing from
algorithms key derivation methods all
these different things but I think two
additional things that really matter in
pain moments more than a lot of other
areas and workload confidentiality data
criticality is important every
organization has their own type of data
no matter what vertical you're in that
is that mission critical data
payments though you're dealing with data
that crosses not only your own
organization's boundary but also a lot
of other stakeholders out there you've
got the card issuing Bank you've got the
organizations that process that data
you've got Merchants you've got the end
consumer with their own payment data all
of that in the event of a breach or
anything like that there's a lot of
Splash damage from that and the risk
factors that come from that and the
desire for everybody not to end up on
the front page of the Wall Street
Journal really is why the payment HSM
ecosystem exists in the way it does one
of the reason why as Todd said
compliance PCI Phipps like Nelly was
saying earlier are so important is just
packaging up everything in a way that
matters from a compliance standpoint
but one of the other things we're seeing
these days that I think is particularly
interesting is a convergence of
different data types and different means
of data protection almost into single
ecosystems where you don't as often
nowadays see people dividing out
workloads or data types into payments or
general purpose or their pki really
forward-thinking organizations are
viewing those as part of the same
overall ecosystem it's now seeing what's
going on with bare metal HSM for
payments building on some of the other
confidential Computing Cloud HSM Cloud
Key Management all of this fits into the
same overall ecosystem I think looking
at it from that direction really is what
we're seeing trending wise
okay but let's take a step back and and
why are
you think about Hardware based controls
why are they so important overall in in
this space and I'll I'll let you start
Adam I'm fair enough yeah well I mean
building again on what Nelly said
earlier it's it's all about that tamper
evidence and tamper responsiveness the
idea being that you take your
cryptographic keys that are protecting
your most sensitive data really whatever
that data is the data type doesn't even
matter but you take the keys that are
being used to encrypt that data to
validate that data to sign that data and
you house those keys inside a tamper
evident tamper responsive ecosystem you
ensure protection not only from outside
threats this handled using the
algorithms the cryptographic techniques
that we're all familiar with but you
also protect from Insider threats you
protect from tampering with that
physical device itself as such that
nobody even people in your own
organization even your most trusted
security admins and employees have no
way to ever get to those keys in the
clear
yeah no
I agree with everything you said Adam I
guess whenever you talk about Hardware
based controls and hsms uh the first H
in HSM is Hardware just you know so it's
pretty evident that we want to make sure
that we're really protecting our in very
important critical Keys as you said Adam
and and hardware and so I think having
the right side of controls and we all
hear about different types of breaches
and hacks that occur where a lot of
those very important credentials and
encryption keys are in software and it's
easy for hackers to get those and once
they have it they have the keys to the
kingdom as we call this uh the session
today so I think hardware-based controls
are important not from a compliance
perspective but also just from a best
practice a best security practice
perspective to make sure that you put
all that in critical information inside
that safe called an HSM and Hardware
okay Nelly thank you so much the only
things that I will add Hardware also
have really small what they call trusted
Computing base
the amount of software or the amount of
firmware that running in Hardware
controls is very limited and as a result
of that as usual as most stuff you run
as most stuff you need to trust with
hardware and Hardware capability and
this former and this very limited
functions that specifically designed for
those separation we ensure all of us
that the hardware is used exactly as
it's supposed to be through enormous
amount testing pen testing Etc and it is
why we believe that Hardware is
providing very strong additional layer
of protection for everything that we do
and it's the same not only with hu
sounds the same is with confidential
Computing why a very reliant on Hardware
CPU extension and Hardware capability to
create this opportunity for us to offer
this functionality to you so absolutely
Hardware is interesting this combination
with the right software and former we
provide really strong security
assurances for all of you
excellent now Nelly we talked a lot
about making this more accessible and
intuitive to use so what would you say
what are some of the sort of things
we're doing to make the complexity of a
data security strategy a little bit more
you know on the table for most
organizations I think
Key Management autopilot is going to
simplify your life enormously
forward for your early feedback on this
capability because again
cryptography is complicated and I'm sure
all of us love to talk about
cryptography but making any mistakes in
this space is really very creates huge
consequences
and the second one usability without
security is absolutely not even the same
again I can give you a few millions of
examples and fantastic security never
provided first of all protection but
also it didn't meet their expectation
and probably some things that you super
familiar with it's called multi-factor
authentication huh
we love multi-factor authentication you
know how many years we as security
Community trying to ensure that our
users our customers are not relying on
passwords alone
I don't know probably 20 years 25 years
and it's still again so complicated to
have this second factor and set factor
and whatever end Factor available for us
for employees for users for everybody so
security and data protection without
usability simply would not fly it will
not work and this is why Google was one
of the first that tried to make
confidential Computing is well usable
compared to whatever was possible before
it was a lot of security and very very
few attention to usability now the whole
industry is working to ensure that your
applications do not need to change the
way how you operate Machinery doesn't
need to change and we creating the
environments that will fit your needs
instead of otherwise around so be
absolutely Paramount on making this
usable for you and we will continue to
listen to your feedback and make our
story even better
yeah well I'll just thanks Nelly that
was perfect I'll just add that I think
Marcus started off this presentation
talking about data there's so much data
being generated and it's sprawling all
over the place
um from our perspective my perspective
getting control of your data sprawl is
through controlling the keys that are
encrypting that data you want to find
out where that critical data is you want
to encrypt you want to maintain those
encryption keys I think from a
complexity perspective it's really being
able to centralize and manage those keys
and I think from all of you it's with
everything the tools that are made
available to you so with Google
workspace you can use client-side
encryption today when it comes to Google
Cloud we've got external Key Management
we've got CMAC customer managed
encryption Keys we also have a hold your
own key or external Key Management we in
beccued as data encryption the idea is
cloud service providers like Google give
you those tools that when you're using
their service they can use the Key
Management Services as well too so to
make it maybe as a first step and I
think that was the question mark is you
know how do you how do you move in to
actually coming up with the data
security strategy leverage the tools
that are given to you start leveraging
those external Key Management those
centralized Key Management tools and
then over time you'll start to add more
use cases but the csps Google in
particular it's giving you all the all
the technology that you need to really
get a start when it comes to protecting
your information from a data security
perspective so hope that's useful maybe
too high level but uh Adam go ahead no I
would I would agree with all that and I
I think one of the barriers historically
to implementing strong encryption and a
good robust data protection strategy has
been around complexity or or maybe
perceived complexity of it and and it is
tough and one of the challenging things
that I've seen historically is that
organizations may be very very quick to
to buy Solutions or services or things
like that but then actually developing
the skill set within their employee base
and maintaining that to actually handle
the care and feeding of these devices
these Technologies sometimes they a
little bit in that and that that can
actually produce some unintended risks
if they think they're in a secure spot
but in reality well maybe they're not
quite where they need to be and you know
for me that's one of the things I'm
excited about about some of these new
technologies is that it takes some of
that workload burden off the End
customer it says all right here are
things that we can do that we know we
can make decisions easier and present
that to the end user and I think that
ultimately will result in a lot greater
adoption of these Technologies a lot
greater protection of that sensitive
data and hopefully a little bit of time
saved along the way too
well like I said before none of this
would have been remotely possible
without the great partnership between
our company so thank you so much for
thank you guys thank you for joining us
[Applause]
[Music]